your brain is making an assumption right
now hello and welcome to another episode
of the lab where we take your questions
and turn them into experiments my name
is Greg and I'm Mitch and today we're
gonna be talking about cool illusions
and why we love them so much so we're
gonna be doing a bunch of weird stuff to
our brains and yours let's start off
with the thing that humans do really
well our brains have evolved to pick up
pattern so for example there's a tiger
hiding in amongst grass and it's
camouflaged like my coat then what will
happen is that our brains will be able
to actually focus on the important
aspects and see the tiger and obviously
this makes sense our brains have evolved
to do this because it helps us
evolutionarily but interestingly your
brain actually wants to ignore all the
other information it's receiving so much
and it's trying to pick out what's
important and what's not and so the
stuff that's not it tries to get rid of
so the solution is gonna be called spot
the difference we haven't actually seen
these images yet but basically it's
gonna be a flashing image and each time
it flashes one thing changes back and
forth we've got a spot what that things
about the difference okay
wait oh oh I
what is it someone well it's funny cuz
once you see it it's like all you can
see it's like I'm just like I do not see
it but oh the shadow oh yeah oh my god
okay so that time curious let us know
how long these take you in the comments
ooh tourism but you spotted already okay
so we got there in France
no fair pain out there in New York see
this is the I shouldn't be ya know like
finding things yeah I'm like oh cool
image I cannot see anything it's like a
pattern in the fence
no what I'm not good at this what does
that mean I'm like I would have died no
no I was like a primitive human never
just been like oh that's a cute
this was interesting because there are
so many faces and things that you would
expect to change like people walking
your brain is like are they moving the
light is something that could change the
cars could be moving but it's something
that you don't necessarily always
anticipate and your brain is actually
making these assumptions that these are
the things that make sense to move on my
I automatically goes to the words and
the people okay I give up okay it's on
the car the window like the reflection
on that is the changing back and forth
oh my god yeah but that was like
discrete cuz it wasn't an R I'm
surprised you even saw next Jeff yeah
from the night Otto so my brain is no
working no having right my brain is
right now going to probably look at the
human or look at the words look at the
things that's a violation airily wanting
to do but I know this is an illusion so
I need to try and find the things I
probably won't move because I've learned
oh the blue box yeah on the screen
disappears in and they do really go down
because the water is behind it so it's a
natural piece that goes I guess that's
part of the solution in that it's
replaced by something that seems normal
ya know those illusions work because our
brains have evolved to focus on things
that they think are important and in
fact leaving and making assumptions
about all the things that Dean's as not
important so now it's time to take a
look at how our brain makes some wrong
assumption we have a variation of
something called the Moirai illusion and
so if we stick these together you'll
start to see something happen
so in this optical illusion you actually
see six different somewhat similar
dinosaurs as one static image but as
soon as you put this grid over top your
brain is tricked into thinking that it's
one dinosaur that's moving so actually
when they first thought of the concept
of film and entertainment for us humans
there were something called as oh trope
which essentially was a static with
static images that were in this like
circular little machine that would spin
and it would create movement so the
first this would have been the first
ever a drastic park people would have
lined up with popcorn just it'll be like
wow it's all tricking your brain okay so
we are here at you soft we are gonna do
some more tricks to your brain so let's
go on inside so you thought this may be
most famous for their games Assassin's
Creed and Splinter Cell just and and
just dance
lots of Gdansk games but what's most
exciting is this emotion capture system
where they're able to suit us up and
then track all of our movements to be in
sync with the characters on screen doing
that right now blue steel okay put on
your fashion do a spin I honestly feel
like you're super into that and I think
for gloves and these on and I think
we're good to go
now you decide which spots exactly so
the top just one marker here it's called
it
so it is just all showing you in detail
how amazing and adapted and evolved
their brains are to be able to look at
these simple dots and patterns and know
that's a human it was really important
to bring it to Mabel it's amazing how
your brain I create so many Sun just as
you can see so much oh you're
interesting even if you don't see the
full human you can like tell the action
Oh to make quickly make assumptions so
you don't have to sit there thinking or
every little thing and you can just
understand your environment in an
instant it was awesome I could not it
was so fun
yeah a wearing these is super cool if
you like superheroes are in a movie text
over the Nana seeing the actual
experience of the stuff up on the screen
and recognizing how little is necessary
was really awesome so now we're gonna
train my brain to make some new
assumptions with this little rig we've
got going so yeah this is obviously a
fake and you couldn't tell and this is
Mitch's real hand and if I touch the
same parts of the fake hand as his real
hand I'm actually able to trick his
brain to actually have a new experience
and then he'll make some different weird
assumptions and essentially start to
feel things in this fake hand and also
the fingers are attached to my fingers
so I kind of can create the sensation
that I'm in control this hand I can't
see my hand at all so oh my gosh that's
so weird as I'm looking at it now it's
starting to be like that he's actually
touching my hand and that this is what's
feeling the sensation since I here what
are you doing
oh that's so weird okay so we've been
doing this long enough that I honestly
like I know in my brain it's not really
my hand but there's something about it
that it just I don't feel I feel like I
have I projected my physical touch onto
this hand it's oh my god what it scared
me it didn't I didn't when you stab it I
didn't feel it like I feel a sensation
but I had the fear that it was going so
I feel like that anticipation of pain I
felt but then obviously I didn't feel
like you stabbed my hand with an exact
don't really mean I was stabbing you it
was kind of fun cathartic release for
gray wow that was really amazing I
highly suggest this is such a simple rig
if you guys at home if you think this is
just like a Halloween fake hand we got
cardboard box just attach these vision
like fishing wire so absolutely I
recommend just trick your brain you have
to hide your own hand and make this set
up and you could do it at home now it's
time for this week in science the idea
that wearing strong perfume can attract
mosquitoes may be a mess researchers
studying effective alternatives to DEET
found that Victoria's Secret's bombshell
perfume was actually almost as good as
its deep counterparts but don't go
running to the shopping mall because
Victoria's Secret bombshell perfume
costs about 50 US dollars whereas DEET
repellent is usually only around 10
dollars and if you actually wear the
scent you're probably used to people
fleeing because the smells were really
bad some good news for our closest
relatives the chimpanzees 98% of our DNA
is the same as our primate relative and
the National Institute of Health has
decided to stop their bio medical
research on chimpanzees as a result 50
chimpanzees are scheduled to be released
to animal sanctuaries with no
nutritional attributes and the source of
1/3 of all the sugar intake in the US
there's a lot of reasons why you
shouldn't be drinking soda so here's
another reason why it's a huge waste of
water for every liter of soft drink
produced there's between 340 to 620
liters of water used to create it thanks
for watching another episode of the lab
you can follow us both on Instagram and
Twitter by using our hand
down here make sure you subscribe to
ASAP signs for more science videos and
we'll see you next Sunday for a new
episode of the lab